[Music]
all right everybody this
is the reuben report direct message i
still
i'm dave rubin and today we're doing
something a little bit different this is
all ask me anything q a
questions can be submitted at
rubinreport.com so already if you are a
member you've already submitted your
questions
uh it looked like we got about 80
questions or so i've got a whole bunch
of them on my fancy ipad here
if you want to submit a question live
right now you can do it on your phone or
on your computer and somehow through the
pipes that al gore
connected way back when to create the
internet your question could show up on
my ipad while i'm sitting here you
sitting at home in your basement naked
at your computer
could get a question to me right now
it's absolutely incredible
just go to reubenreport.com sign up and
you can
submit a question and we're going to do
this probably every couple weeks just so
that uh i'm not just
doing sort of news stuff all the time
although there's a lot of news related
questions
i actually find that uh getting info
from you guys and getting questions from
you guys and finding out what's on your
mind is usually more informative and
well
it's always more informative than what
i'm going to get from the blue check
twitter brigade
but it's often more informative than
just paying attention to the news in
general because
uh good regular decent people have
interesting things on their minds
believe it or not despite
what the media will tell you uh before i
dive in
i just want to tell you one funny thing
that happened this morning so we were we
were walking clyde this morning walking
the dog
and uh i was dressed not like i'm
usually dressed here i'm wearing like a
ripped
uh workout thing because i did some
cardio this morning and i'm wearing like
old beat up shorts and flip-flops
and david's with me and we're walking
clyde and this guy drives down the
street and he's in a camaro
uh you know top-down sunglasses
young guy and he's like yo dave love the
show man love all the content blah blah
blah he stops the car
kind of in the middle of the street and
there's cars behind him and
i was like oh great thanks man this
woman
this woman's walking this way like she's
walking towards me i don't think she
really knew who i am but i didn't have a
mask on
and she looked at me and she's like and
i was like and then she kind of like
jumped off the curb to walk around me
and i was like that's just such like a
perfect like synopsis at least
probably what your lives are like at
some level but certainly what my life is
like
like sort of good and bad just like
happening all the time like this nice
guy
clearly he had his stuff together he's
in a cool car like looks like he's like
doing something in life says something
nice to me
and then like because i stopped for a
moment on the sidewalk this
one and then she just walked off the
curb almost got hit by a car herself
and then uh walked away anyway i just
thought that was a little silly
something
all right here we go i'm going to try to
do as many questions as possible i will
not be wordy i'm going to get to it
because we got a jill
a gazillion of them i might abbreviate
some of your questions here i'm going to
start with lauren
who asked how can we reclaim the
narrative on systemic racism in law
enforcement
the rhetoric has resulted in increasing
numbers of police officers being
attacked and resigning from their field
what can we do to challenge the ongoing
selective media coverage
of police killings all right so first
off there
the media cnn new york times the rest of
the drivel
archaic media that at this point has to
collapse
um they are not going to stop there is
nothing
that can be done social justice has
infected
and woke-ism has infected these
institutions to the point
that they will die on their sword right
they that we
know they're going this route um they
will not turn around
and the host has been infected um but
what we can do and what you can do
is what i think you're probably doing
already if if you're watching me right
now what you can do is
you can send your friends videos that
debunk a lot of this nonsense so
obviously there's a bunch of prageru
videos on this
but i would recommend i mean clearly if
i'm just talking about stuff that i've
done
send people any of my interviews with
larry elder including the
famous first one where he beat me
senseless when i claimed that systemic
racism existed this is now four or five
years ago and obviously
as you guys know it was one of my
political awakening moments
send people thomas soul videos give them
a book
i know these are like little micro
things and it doesn't feel like we can
like fix the whole system just with what
you do in your life
but i can tell you this i can tell you
this that when we were rebuilding the
studio
this studio here um we have a friend who
we've done some work with who's uh who's
a lifelong lefty lefty lefty was a
was a bernie person then a hillary
supporter the whole thing
you know hates trump all of that stuff
and
uh i gave him a copy of my book a couple
weeks ago as we were rebuilding the
studio
and he's emailed me a couple times he's
not like a hugely political person
um but definitely like a lefty you know
just sort of a factory settings lefty
and he's emailed me a couple of times
basically saying huh
you know there is some interesting stuff
in here and maybe i'm a little more
libertarian than i thought
so if you want to debunk systemic racism
you can't get into the fight with your
friend and just start laying out
numbers like it just doesn't work
they'll be like oh those are the numbers
that you're just selecting from fox news
and blah blah blah
and that is one of the problems that
we're all sort of selecting what facts
we agree on and
that's why i keep saying there's a war
on reality but i think
if you send people some easy short
digestible videos
um that's probably the best way that you
can do it
and then the other thing that you can do
is just make sure
you're finding new information and don't
get lost in your own bubble right i mean
we all get stuck in this thing myself
included and
and you know just be open to new
information and
and just try to be a little better try
to be a little better than the people
that will scream you down
the second you say no systemic racism
doesn't exist meaning there are no laws
that stop anyone from doing anything
based on the color of their skin that is
absolutely true there are no laws if
there was a law
that said black people cannot do this
because of the color of their skin
or if there was a law it doesn't have to
be about racism that said women cannot
do this
because of their gender gay people
cannot do this because
of their sexuality of course i would be
against that i'm for individual rights
equality for everybody
and i think if you can get some simple
ideas across to people first
then you can sort of let them uh get to
where they need to get to okay i'm going
to try to do it faster
this is kelvin he says assuming abide in
democrat win in november by whatever
means do you imagine that the pandemic
will suddenly disappear
or at least cease to be any kind of
priority to such administration
ah so you know look this is one of those
things where it's like we're all kind of
conspiracy theories uh theorists these
days because everything is so crazy but
i do
sense that if biden wins i do not think
biden is going to win and i think
there's a couple other questions related
to that here
um that if biden wins suddenly the
pandemic won't be so bad
suddenly the states will start opening
up suddenly
things won't be as needed to be locked
down apparently as they are by the way
there's an incredible story if you have
not heard this you gotta google it
there is an incredible story breaking
this morning out of nashville which by
the way
ben shapiro and the the daily wire just
announced i believe yesterday i've known
it for a little bit
that they are moving to nashville and
then this morning this story breaks out
in nashville
that in effect uh the the public
uh the politicians in effect were hiding
information on kovid because the numbers
were so
low and thus that allowed them to keep
bars and restaurants open
it's an absolutely absolutely crazy
story and by the way i think there's
going to be many more stories like this
breaking where we're going to find out
that there are scandals massive massive
scandals
happening in los angeles happening in
new york most likely happening wherever
you live
that authorities have kept things on
lockdown
longer than they should have they hid
information and i think
i think 2021 i just tweeted this out i
think 2021 is going to be
uh littered with lawsuits class
action lawsuits all sorts of stuff
because
politicians have decided to put whatever
their political ambitions are or
whatever it is that they seem to want
control over you they've put that ahead
of your ability
uh for life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness um
so i do sense that that things would
kind of go away if biden
became president i don't think in and of
itself that's a reason to vote
for uh joe biden um this is sort of an
offshoot of that this is aaron who says
do you think we'll ever get back to a
normal society without masks
or do you think that we will now become
a country where people routinely wear
masks when out in public
i think no matter what happens i mean
first off you can even see it
biden said today this thing about uh
you know i trust scientists that's their
new thing i trust science well first off
well okay you trust science that's great
and and i believe that science
is the pursuit of truth and science can
do amazing things but they always say i
trust science
as if science can't be wrong but science
is also the the quest to prove that the
science before you is wrong right like
there's theories and then theories get
debunked and then we get new theories
and these things are
tested and proven and all of this so is
i believe in science
that's like saying i believe in air okay
well yes i believe in air
that doesn't really mean anything but
anyway biden said this thing this
morning about
how he trusts science and the cdc
uh about a vaccine but he doesn't trust
donald trump
but what does that mean what are you
saying then if if the cdc comes up with
a
vaccine under the trump administration
do you think trump is the one that's
doing the science in the lab i mean just
trying to picture
trump in a in a lab jacket and glasses
you know doing the science to create
the vaccines it's so stupid um but i
think the problem is that we're just
undermining each other at all turns
right so the the democrats
are going to say if it came from a trump
administration then the vaccine is no
good and
you can do the other version of that
obviously um what i do think will happen
is as
as corona goes away or as the lockdowns
go away or just the idea of whatever the
freaking hell is going on right now
as it goes away you're going to see
certain people that listen to certain
types of news who are always going to be
wearing masks you know when you go to
the airport and we get a lot of this in
los angeles because it's obviously a
major
a major hub around the world you would
often see people
uh from asian countries china
specifically that would be wearing masks
at the airport and you'd always be like
well
what's going on here or you know this is
before coronavirus i mean are
are they sick are they afraid we're
going to get them sick like what's going
on here
i think you're just gonna see more and
more of that which is which is
depressing in a way because one of the
things that i miss i even i went to the
supermarket yesterday
and it's like you know you go in there
and you know i had a hat on and i had
glasses and i had a mask
like you see i don't know i guess you
could see this part of my face
and then like you talk to the the
cashier and you can't really see her
face because she's got
a mask on or whatever else it is it's
like we're losing and then we sit at our
computers all day and we just chat with
people
so it's like we're losing all of that
like actual interpersonal stuff and i
think there's going to be a real drive
for it
and this is why by the way at the
beginning of the lockdown i said you
know when we get through this thing and
we will get through it and i mean this
more now than i even meant it then
i think the roaring 20s will be here
because people are wanting are going to
want to be out and about and connecting
and having fun and enjoying themselves
and as i said yesterday there is a lot
of good news in the world it's just a
little harder to see it
okay ken asks would you be able to
interview joe jorgensen so a ton of
people have asked me this
we had a little scheduling conflict joe
jorgensen is the libertarian
presidential candidate
we are interviewing her i believe we're
doing it next week and then it'll air
the week after or roughly something like
that and i'm looking forward to it
and as you guys know i voted for gary
johnson the libertarian last time
um i will talk to her about all of the
things that i think are right about
libertarian ideas but wrong with the
libertarian party and
let's see what she says okay uh alex
says what are your thoughts on shapiro
and the daily wire leaving california
look i'm glad you asked this
um because i had talks with shapiro
about this a couple months ago because
there had been
rumblings about this for quite some time
i had had dinner with
michael knowles at my place during the
lockdown oh no i just
probably got arrested the stormtroopers
are going to be here any minute from
gavin newsom stormtroopers you went
dinner with someone months ago
um so i had known this thing was coming
i didn't necessarily know it was going
to be nashville there were a couple
options
but i had talked to these guys about it
and you know look at a business level
they're going to save a ton in taxes at
a
sort of personal level i think the
the ideas that that ben and the daily
wire guys are putting forth conservative
ideas they're not uh
that well liked in los angeles and in
california and
they're doing a move that is totally
congruent with their belief system so i
i think that's great i think it's
unfortunate
if someone like ben who was born in los
angeles and he and his
folks and whoever else like if these
types of people
can't live in los angeles this is a huge
problem now that being said when i had
these discussions with these guys david
and i had discussions with ourselves and
everything else
and we were watching the riots happen
and you know because
excuse me because i had a studio in my
house uh the other studio at least
i had had tons of people coming in and
out of my house and everyone knew
where i live and you're not going to
believe this guys but there are people
out there that don't like me so i had
other security concerns and everything
else
so we really thought about moving and we
looked at real estate and houses in
texas we looked in florida
we actually did look in tennessee as
well in the nashville area
and this was all independent of the of
the daily wire guys and i really thought
about it and then
i just i had a conversation with knowles
and i just felt you know if someone like
me
so if a disaffected liberal who i would
say at this point is just a
a modern conservative um because the
conservative movement has become sort of
wider and more open and everything else
if someone like me can't live in los
angeles can't live in california
then then what dennis prager always
described as the american experiment
well then it's done
right like if i can't live here then
what then what if i can't live here then
how does someone in texas
have anything in common with someone
in california now i know a lot of people
are saying well we should have this like
mass separation or let california go its
own way or all of those things
and i think those things are all fine to
talk about um
but i'm not ready to give up yet and
i'll say something else you know when
over the last couple months because of
the lockdown you know i've met many more
of my neighbors in our old place and
and in this new place and when i'm
walking around and people come up to me
oh dave i saw you on fox news i love the
show whatever it is
it's their way of saying hey i'm not a
crazy brain dead lefty
and i'm getting more and more and more
of those people and i told you how i've
been seeing in our new neighborhood lots
of american flags
which to me that's a subtle symbol that
you're not a lefty at this point because
what lefty is going to put up an
american flag if this whole thing is an
evil racist patriarchal founded on
slavery
project right so i think that there is
an awakening
and things are cyclical usually the left
ruins things with big government
and then the right sort of fixes them
you know i come from new york new york
city had david dinkins
he was a far lefty progressive he ruined
new york city
times square i mean my grandparents and
my great-grandparents lived in new york
city we would go in i remember i was a
kid
and it was disgusting and i could my
parents were always like holding us real
tight
and eventually you know what happened
rudy giuliani came in and fixed the
whole city and now de blasio's ruining
it again so these things are cyclical
but one other thing on this which is
that uh i was watching a couple months
ago
this netflix documentary on frank
sinatra it's a two episode two hours
each documentary it's really wonderful
even if you don't love the music i do
love the music but just a really
interesting
sort of take on on celebrity and
hollywood and and just the rat pack and
it's really awesome
but i forgot really how politically
involved frank sinatra was in sinatra
you know he's a jersey new york city guy
and he was a democrat his whole life
obviously friends with jfk
and fundraised for the democrats his
whole life and as he got a little older
guess what he started becoming it wasn't
that he became more conservative exactly
he sort of did
but also sort of saw the left kind of
going off the deep end after jfk
and you know what he did he became good
friends with ronald reagan a hollywood
actor who then became a conservative
governor of california
and then and then what's really
interesting about the documentary is
then they go into how the media suddenly
turned on him that he was the darling of
the media but then once he became
friends with those scary conservatives
that suddenly
suddenly he was the bad guy but there's
a great moment in the movie where where
sinatra says something to the effect of
every man has a right to stand up and
have their voice
heard and stand up and vote for who they
think is right
and he sort of talks about how the mob
and the media try to get you from that
and that you know this is like
40 50 years ago 50 years ago roughly so
it's really
really really interesting thing and i so
long story short i'm gonna stay and
fight i think we can fix this thing
i really really believe it and i'm gonna
try for a while there are good people in
california you know peter thiel is down
here
uh rick grinnell is here like there are
people that are waking up and we just
we got work to do we got work to do but
what better stuff do i have to do okay
um steve you sort of asked a very uh
similar question about you're a fourth
generation southern californian and you
want to stay and fight as well
um okay that's great man appreciate it
um
ben says tell me where i'm wrong in my
case for pending alien invasion he had
posted something in the community
earlier about alien invasion
anything's possible at this point as i
said to as i said to knowles when i got
back on the grid you could tell me that
aliens invaded
you could tell me joe biden's head
exploded you could tell me actually
anything and it would be like yeah kind
of makes sense that's sort of where
we're at at the moment
um maybe an alien invasion would be the
thing that would kind of cause that
national cohesion that we need you know
that that might be it
um truman asks what's the most
ridiculous reason you've been given for
being demonetized
um you know what's the most well usually
it's just completely arbitrary
and it's and it's very hard to figure
out we've got a great guy on our team
chris who i know
is watching this and he's an unheralded
hero of our team who's done a really
really great job working with our
our youtube contact about cleaning up a
lot of stuff so we don't get hit as hard
as we used to
one of the videos that i did last week
oh the video that i did
the direct message that i did on 911 was
temporarily demonetized then it gets
monetized
uh but look that's why i created
rubinreport.com what i'm more concerned
about the demonetization rather than the
money is that it hurts it in the
algorithm so less people see the videos
it's not even really about the money
it's that i want people to be able to
to see the videos so in terms of
reasoning you know i don't expect them
to give us honest answers and when i say
them i don't expect honest answers from
youtube
i don't expect honest answers from
twitter i don't expect honest answers
from facebook or the rest of it
as you guys know we're doing this cancel
con thing tonight so i'll be heading
over to corolla's studio this afternoon
and i'll be there with shapiro and
prager
and for the last basically two weeks the
cancel con guys have been trying to buy
ads on facebook i think around ten
thousand dollars worth of ads
that means that as a business they're
trying to give business
to facebook and facebook won't let them
advertise the point of the whole
freaking
no safe spaces movie and the point of
the cancel con event by the way you can
check it out tonight i think it's on at
5 p.m
eastern 5 pm pacific 8 pm eastern
no safe spaces dot com dragonfly
no question just a shout out going to
see my family for the first time this
year
effin kobit right on man i haven't seen
any of my family i haven't seen
my folks i haven't seen my brother my
sister my nieces my nephews we face time
all the time
we zoom we do all that stuff normally uh
you know tomorrow night starts rosh
hashanah it's the jewish new year
normally i would i would be home with
family
going to do it this year like it's just
it's just a really ridiculous thing and
and
going back to what i said earlier about
you know these politicians who've closed
down businesses and stopped families
being together and we've all heard the
horrible stories of people
who haven't been able to go to their
grandparents funeral or whatever it
might be
it's like i think massive lawsuits are
coming i think massive massive lawsuits
are coming
uh chris says do you have a prediction
for the u.s election and it's aftermath
uh i'll go against what everyone's
saying right now and what the polls are
saying
uh i think trump is going to win i think
he's going to win by a surprisingly
large
margin i think people have just had it
they have just had it with identity
politics they have just had it
with cities burning they are they are
shocked and elated and amazed that that
we're heading towards a peaceful future
for the middle east
um they're realizing that you know that
trump for his imperfections which
obviously exists he's not a racist he's
not a homophobe he's trying to keep
the wheels on the system um and i think
just that the if you're the average
person in the middle
it's like all right you can vote for
trump or you may have some reservations
for
or you can vote for a guy who seemingly
has the beginnings of dementia
with a vp who nobody liked and the the
base got her out really quick right she
was dropped out really quick
and then she's gonna be president and
what sits beneath that
is all of the marxist socialist nonsense
that's burning down cities i just don't
see how people break that way
but of course it'll come out to voter
turnout and everything else and what
happens over the next six weeks who the
hell knows and
let's not forget you can already see the
media is priming this
to not accept the results of the
election because i think they are
starting to realize that trump's looking
pretty good right now
and they're already going to try to
figure out what trump's not going to
step down
they're meaning like he won't accept the
results of the election except this is
coming from the same people who haven't
accepted the results for the last four
years
uh heavy metal homo says
a silly question but how do you stay
thin while married to an amazing cook
are you still on paleo um i try to do
cardio every day
i try to do like 45 minutes to an hour
of cardio every day i say this all the
time i watch old basketball games
uh i just or sometimes i watch old
cartoons i literally watch the
thundercats
and gi joe and transformers like the 80s
cartoons that's basically what i watch i
just watched the gi joe movie
uh which was so freaking spectacular
it's just absolute perfection um so i
try to do cardio every day
um i never drink soda um
what else do i do i don't eat a lot of
bread i'm not really doing paleo but
i basically eat meat and veggies and
then occasionally some ice cream but
that that's pretty
that's pretty much it um lauren when is
your next book coming out so i don't
know that i've actually fully said this
publicly but i did sign on for my second
book uh it looks like it will be
published
in the spring of 2022 because the book
publishing process takes a seriously
long time
um and i'm not ready to announce the
title yet i do have a tentative title
that i'm
like ninety percent sure it's going to
be and i've written the the uh the
outline already
and i've sort of sketched out you know
kind of where i'm going to go with this
whole thing and i think it really is
going to be
sort of the next evolution of everything
i'm doing i think you're going to dig it
um so i'll have a little more info on
that soon i haven't really started
writing it yet i want to get through the
election and then i'll dive in for there
uh miriam says are you planning to run
for governor of california good god
if i had uh a nickel for everybody
that's asking me this i'd have a couple
bucks probably a decent amount of people
ask me
um i don't know that my skill set
is best suited to run for this stuff we
need good people to run
you know politics is so messy and it's
so dirty
and i think part of the problem is it's
designed that way so that good people
won't get involved right because someone
like me i suppose
should run i i don't know that that's
really my future i think i'm going to
keep doing this and see see how i can
affect things
james says who and when was the last
time someone changed your mind with
something big in your life
i mean the easy answer on this that you
guys all know is larry eller beating me
senseless about systemic racism that's
the one that
it changed the course of my life like it
changed a personal political belief
but then because of that changed the
total course of my life um
on a more personal note i would say
touring with jordan and i write about
this in
uh in chapter nine of the book uh being
around him and seeing the way he lived
his life and how that
how living honestly for him uh helped
other people live honestly for
themselves it absolutely
helped me as a person and i hope maybe
i've imparted a tiny bit of that to you
guys too
uh i know we're over time here i'm going
to push it a couple minutes
that's what i'm going to do because the
people demand it um
dan says what do you think about the
scientist that's saying corona was
created in a lab the content is being
censored but is that just because it
doesn't follow the narrative or because
she's not a legitimate source
so there is a woman who i think was a
scientist in a lab in wuhan
and i might i haven't read this full
story but i know a little bit about it i
saw it very quickly on twitter
it's been pretty busy around here uh who
is claiming that
there is proof that the that covet was
created in a lab
uh in china so i don't know what i don't
know what the truth is and i don't know
enough about her it sounds like nobody
does i guess she was on
tucker carlson uh a night or two ago uh
what i think is
as disturbing is the fact that perhaps
it was created in the lab
is the fact that uh youtube and facebook
and the rest of them are taking down
videos related to this
it's like how about you leave
information up there you guys have
decided to be
the arbiters of truth and this is a big
problem because you know first they told
us not to wear masks then we were
supposed to wear a mask then we weren't
supposed to wear max
this is what was coming out of the cdc
and the who it's like should we ban
their accounts
but we know this usually only goes one
way all right i'm gonna try to push it a
little bit more
um let's see um i'm observing this is
interesting freedom fan i'm observing
seniors in their 70s and 80s who rely on
traditional media growing more
liberal and prone to believe that
america's racist flawed etc
i chalk it up to accepting traditional
media as being honest and or trying to
stay relevant with younger family
members is it just me or if you notice a
similar trend
wow that's really disturbing if true
because
generally i sort of referenced this
before people get more conservative
as they get older because they start
realizing oh you have to conserve
the good things from generations before
that that made things
so good and things are pretty freaking
good here
um so that would be pretty disturbing
i've heard a little i have one
uh anecdotal story about uh a friend of
mine who's grandmother who's a wonderful
lady who i've i've known my whole life
um and she happens to be a conservative
that she posted one of my clips
one of my clips and her grandchildren
started going after her on facebook and
then it became a huge family blowout
because they had to ask
her to take it down and then the parents
were upset with the kids about going
after grandma publicly so that's not
exactly what you're saying here because
she was taking her
conservative position but i could see
that i could see a situation where older
grandparents are just like kind of
grandparents and parents kind of throw
up their hands because
the the kids have been raised to think
that everything is so evil and racist
and that that is a dangerous thought man
ooh
enough to think about that a little bit
more matt you seem like a smart and
sensible
individual would you ever consider
running for office we did that at state
local or federal
maybe when i'm like 65 and i retire and
i'm pretty much disappeared and i'm not
public anymore
i would become a mayor of somewhere
little all right one more guys uh and i
i will we're going to keep doing these
so please keep submitting questions
and there's a ton of great ones here i'm
sorry if i didn't get to you um and the
last one
not political hope asks are you watching
anything good right now or recently
as you guys know when lockdown started i
i watched all of the sopranos from the
beginning which is like
it's perfection there's not a minute
wasted in the entire series it's just
absolute
perfection um the things that i usually
watch as i said i'm watching old
basketball and gi joe and transformers
when i'm doing cardio but at night if if
david and i are trying to watch
something
um we did we uh what are we doing what
are we doing oh
uh on hbo we're watching raised by
wolves which just started there are five
episodes we just watched the fifth one
last night
it's got sort of a star trek star wars
feel to it ridley scott did it
who did aliens who's an incredible
sci-fi director
i'm liking it i'm not like totally wowed
by it i did see mandalorians coming back
that looks pretty good so i'm excited
for that and then last night because i
can't always just watch
dramas and all that stuff um i watch
chef's table on netflix which they have
a serie a mini series within it now just
about barbecues
and i've been barbecuing i am making so
many amazing steaks
i post some pictures of it if you're
following me at the reuben report
community
um but i've been making some really
amazing stuff so i've really been into
just barbecue
techniques and stuff so they did one
about this barbecue down in texas
with this woman named tootsie who like
is 85
and she's out there with the coals every
day like working 12 14 hours every day
and she's been doing it for years
she doesn't even uh use a thermometer in
the in the
uh in the ovens and in the grills on the
grills she just puts her hand on it to
feel like
just really just wonderful story of a
person that like found their passion and
does something that brings happiness and
joy and food to
all sorts of people all right guys that
was a q a i think it was pretty solid
although i didn't get to as many
questions as i wanted to but thanks for
playing along if you want to be involved
in any of these
q and a's that we're going to do as part
of the direct message every couple weeks
you can just sign up for a free account
over at rubinreport.com i thank you for
watching i hope you feel a tiny bit
saner and maybe you take a little
something
that you got here and you hand it off to
somebody else have a great day everybody
i'll see you later